- What did you wanna be when you grew up?
- Are your parents disappointed of you?
(upbeat music)
(playful music)
- What was your dream
job when you were a kid?
- When I was a kid, I wanted to be a chef.
- Are you a chef now?
- I'm a food studies major.
- That makes no sense to me.
- What did you wanna be when you grew up?
- A taxi driver.
- My dream job was being a lawyer.
- What are you now?
- Interaction design.
- Are you a lawyer now?
- I am not a lawyer now.
- Do you even drive a car?
- No, I cannot drive.
(laughs)
- You're really bummin' me out.
- So what was your dream
job when you were a kid?
- So like most kids, I
wanted to be an astronaut.
- I wanted to be an astronaut.
- Are you a astronaut now?
- No, I'm actually a yogi teacher now.
Like I'm a yogi instructor.
- I'm still tryin' to figure it out.
- Well, I wanted to be an architect.
- What does that even mean?
- Architect would design buildings.
- That's all I need to hear, sir.
- Okay.
- Why did you give up your dream?
- I lost interest in
what I wanted as a kid.
- That sounds like a excuse.
- I research Amish women
and ultra-Orthodox women.
- Are you trying to put me to sleep?
- Why did you give up on your dream?
- I didn't really give up on my dream,
it just sorta changed.
- So what was your dream
job when you were a kid?
- I wanted to be a
dancer when I was a kid.
- Are you a dancer now?
- I am.
- Congratulations, you did it.
- Thanks.
(laughs)
- When I was a kid, I
had a million dreams.
But one of them was to be a taxi driver.
- So are you a taxi driver now?
- I never did become.
It was a dream when I was much younger
and dreams change as you go
through different things.
- Do you have any other dreams?
- I have a million dreams.
- I think you could reach your dream.
- Wow, I'm glad that you said that.
It gives me more confidence.
(playful music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel
and now your part.
- Subscribe here.
That was my part.